One of my very favorite trips that I've ever been on
was a Mediterranean cruise
that Daniel and I took when we were very first married.
Because still to this day,
we talk about the euros that we had.
They were so good. And there was so. Yeah,
the meat, the veggies,
the feta, it was also good.
So today I'm making a homemade euro.
Getting started on my meat.
So I put tons of herbs, bread crumbs,
some spices, and then I put it in a loaf pan and baked that.
Then while that was baking,
I rolled out my sourdough pita.
And pita is literally so easy to make.
I started this morning. It's already ready to go.
You just roll them out, put them in the hot skillet,
and then as soon as they're done,
you brush them with melted butter so they stay soft.
Then last night, I soak some garbanzo beans overnight.
Then we cooked them in garlic and sage and some salt,
and then we made our homemade hummus,
which was so creamy and so good.
And then, um,
the meat was done. I sliced it thin,
and then we sauteed it in some butter,
and then we just cut all our veggies,
all the tomatoes, cause they're so good right now.
And then we assembled this.
We got our pita, homemade hummus,
loaded the veggies, meat,
and, of course,
lots of feta.
Oh, man.
And you guys. So good.
It's our favorite. It's Both Daniel and I's one of our favorite foods.